und wenn Sie einmal in den Fängen vom Arbeitslosen
vom Arbeitsamt sind Arbeitslosenamt ja das tritt
eigentlich ganz gut wenn Sie einmal in den
Fängen vom Arbeitsamt sind das ist kein Spaß
deswegen möchte ich sie jetzt mal bitten mir
in eine Szene zu folgen die Szene spielt im
Arbeitsamt ich möchte vorne weg sagen die oh da
fallen schon die Gläser Arbeitsamt der Schrecken
der Menschheit also ich möchte vorne weg sagen
die Geschichte hinter dieser Szene ist exakt so
passiert die Szene dazu habe ich mir ausgedacht
also ich spiele den Fallmanager im Arbeitsamt
so schönen guten Tag Frau Falk Flack Frack na ja
ist ja auch egal letztendlich sind für uns ja nur
eine Nummer na wo drückt denn der Schuh immer
noch arbeitslos aha aha aha woran liegt ach sie
meinten sie sein zu alt um Job zu finden jetzt
kommen Sie mir nicht mit so billigen Ausreden
wie alt sind Sie denn ja stimmt 61 hier steht's
ja auch ich meine gut haben sie noch vi Jahre bis
zur Rente ne kein Grund sich auf die faut zu
legen kenn sie den kommt ein Mann nach Hause
will sich entspannen auf die faule Haut legen
ist die alte nicht da [Gelächter] [Applaus]
ja wie finden sie nicht lustig kein Humor okay
macht sie nicht leichter vermittelbar ne haben
sich denn beworben überall sagen sie aha aha aha
auch als Verkäuferin ach sie waren Verkäuferin
40 Jahre lang das so super dann haben sie doch
Berufserfahrung wie muss ich das verstehen genau
das ist das Problem ja stimmt da haben sie
natürlich recht weil jüngere Arbeitskräfte
billiger sind ne und wenn wir ehrlich sind
auch atttrraktiver verfrag nicht wah ach soo
Flag ja und kein Humor hatte ich mir ja
auch schon notiert so was mache ich denn
da mit ihnen was mache ich denn da mit ihnen
sind sie denn bereit ein Praktikum zu machen
ist natürlich eine rhetorische Frage wenn sie nein
sagen kürze ich ihn die Mittel sie freuen sich auf
das Praktikum schau an so viel Antrieb noch in
ihrem Alter Respekt da schaue ich mal was habe
ich denn da für sie lassen sich mal gucken ja hier
habe ich was Schönes für Sie Praktikum im Kaufhaus
Schröpfer ach das sind die die sie entlassen
haben nach 40 Jahren Betriebszugehörigkeit
weil sie zu alt und zu teuer waren ist ein
Ding ne sehen Sie dann ist das Praktikum doch
die ideale Lösung für Sie sie kennen sich aus
kosten kein Geld und so ein Praktikum verjüngt
ungemein
leider leider eine wahre Geschichte
ein der Mutter eines Freundes von mir
genauso passiert und jetzt gibt Rente mit 60 das
heißt wir können alle mit 66 noch ein Praktikum
angeboten bekommen dann können wir alle singen
mit 66 Jahren da fängt das Praktikum an mit 66
Jahren da hat man Spaß daran und neulich
war wieder so ein klugscheiße im Publikum
hat gesagt ja das kann ja gar nicht stimmen
das heißt ja auch gar nicht mehr Arbeitsamt
das heißt Agentur für Arbeit als ob ein
Namenswechsel was an den Verhältnissen
ändern würde aber gut Lehrer müssen ja
auch irgendwo hin in ihrer Freizeit danke
schön